did you see the interview that i had
with luke where he mentioned somber this
word somber okay what do you think he
not meant by the word but meant by the
implications
that the world would be somber
i
i wish i could tell you what i
i'm being told right now but i don't
think it's responsible for me to talk
about it until i've been able to verify
it more because i don't want to panic
people or
be irresponsible
i'm already copying a swipe from
different people actually eric davis had
a go at me the other day because i um
i apparently talked about um
uh
people who told me that the united
states may be actively engaged in
attempting to bring down objects by
using the frequencies that they know
these objects can be tracked at
and uh he said i was clueless on that
point and
i don't want to get a ding dong with
eric davis because i actually like the
guy and respect him enormously but
all i was doing was reporting what i've
been told
and i've been told
in another area certain things about the
phenomenon that are quite disturbing
i mean there are a lot of people
privately claiming to me
things about the implications of the
phenomenon that that go beyond far
beyond the whole notion of just i mean i
wish it was as simple as
extraterrestrials getting in their
little spaceships and flying from
zeta reticuli and coming to this planet
that's the easy explanation
the
the explanation that
i've been exploring in recent months is
more complex and i've already spoken
about this to some extent so i will say
it involves the notion of
future human
time
time travel
and look it's only hypothetical i'm not
i'm not saying it's real but if what i'm
being told about that is true then yeah
i i would be somber too
why is that somber why is the fact or
the potential that it might be humans
in the future
terrifying because of what it
well i think i wouldn't be giving too
much away if i said that
you think about it
why since 1947
has there been a phenomenon taking an
interest in the human race particularly
in nuclear weapons
why is something or someone
apparently trying to send us a message
about nuclear weapons
why is it that nuclear weapons are being
shut down by
what slide 9 refers to as
remote sensor disassembly
what's it trying to say
what's coming
imagine if and i'm only speaking
hypothetically here
imagine if
future humans knew that if we continue
on the path we're going there's going to
be a nuclear war or a conflagration at
some time
wouldn't you want to head that off
wouldn't you want to protect your kin
and
imagine if you were somebody in the u.s
defense and intelligence establishment
that was aware of that quite insane
sounding idea that this might be a
time thing
a future war thing
and imagine if you're worried that
anything you do
might
jeopardize that time stream
ah i see that's interesting
that's
where i'm
working at the moment and i don't know
if i'll ever get an answer and i'm and i
hasten to add before anybody goes off
and says cultart says blah i'm not
saying this for sure i'm just exploring
this as a hypothetical possibility
you're so amazing
i'm surprising and and that's what we
should do you know we should explore
this but a number of people have put to
me and uh you know they've suggested to
me that this might be future human
and uh there's a great actually there's
a lovely fella michael masters uh it's
not because of his book that i'm doing
this but i commend to people michael's
explored this possibility in his
wonderful book dr michael masters
but the people that i'm talking to are
people inside the
the people who know
see when you say that it might be future
okay possibly
supposing that it might be people from
the future coming back because perhaps
we annihilate ourselves at some point
maybe there's a remnant left and they
don't want that to happen to them
this is me surmising based on what
you've said
what occurs to me is well why don't why
not be more direct about it no you may
say oh yeah one may say
okay the shutting down of nukes is
direct but absolutely i mean someone you
make my you make my day by saying that
because i've had a conversation with
somebody recently where i've said
well okay hypothetically assuming that
it is that
how do you know that being open and
transparent isn't the very thing that
would fix the trend the time stream you
know how do you know that that wouldn't
be the very thing that makes humanity go
oh my god it's real
we're going to screw up this planet if
we don't fix it
i don't know my friend i just don't know
but i mean all i'm doing is exploring
that as a surmised hypothetical
possibility
because the other thing that is possible
here is just flat disinformation you
know as i said at the very beginning of
this conversation
intelligence services lie all the time
and
one of the things as a journalist you
have to do
is try and figure out what are the what
are the little nuggets in the middle of
all of that that are possibly truthful
then how would that make sense with the
that's why i asked you earlier about the
one case where they turned it on what
would be the point of that
uh
i mean hypothetically perhaps it was to
scare the woolies
yeah i know perhaps perhaps it was to
scare the willies out of the kremlin as
much as it scared the willies out of the
pentagon to make them realize that that
thinking of using nuclear weapons in a
defensive capacity is utterly
irresponsible and wrong
and that humanity needs to wake up to
itself and realize that we can't
continue on this course i mean the cold
war ended in 1989
i can remember as a young man i watched
a film called the day after which was a
representation in a film of what it
would look like for a nuclear war
and i genuinely i did not expect as a
teenage kid to survive the cold war i
really didn't expect to get into
adulthood
people have forgotten
how bleak things were
you know when ronald reagan for example
was talking about the evil empire
there was talk about the strategic
defense initiative star wars
you know the russians were basically
demonized the whole soviet bloc was
demonized we didn't think of them as
human we were basically taught to think
of them as
evil authoritarian communists
which
there was evil there was authoritarian
and there was nastiness but they were
human beings as well and
i mean ultimately maybe maybe at the
heart of all of this there is an
intelligence that's trying to make us
think of
what we are we're human
and maybe it's in despair because we're
not listening
because seriously i mean i had a
conversation with an indian journalist
just the other day talking about the
confrontations between india and
pakistan
and how
there is genuine concern inside the
indian military
that
the objects that they're seeing on an
increasing basis there the the anomalous
mysterious objects that they're seeing
over their nuclear weapons might
cause some kind of preemptive strike by
one against the other
and uh you know
i know that this is a concern inside
america i mean we've we've come very
close in the past
to
almost launching nuclear weapons because
of anomalous objects seen on radar
systems
you know it is ridiculous that in this
day and age we still live i mean there's
a great book the hero of the pentagon
papers daniel ellsberg
wrote a fantastic book about the work
that he did before he became the
renowned
whistleblower for the pentagon papers
that led to the revelations about the
dirty secrets the vietnam war
he was also retained by mcnamara the
defense secretary to review
the safety and the security of america's
nuclear weapons strategic nuclear
weapons
and what he found was horrifying and i
recommend i commend his book to anyone
because i think it's one of the most
important books i've read in years
because it actually showed that contrary
to what the public had been being told
generals military commanders had
delegated the decision making on the law
on the launch of nuclear weapons to
individual commanders in some locations
because they they were worried that
the way that the accountability controls
were set up for the launch of nuclear
weapons
it might not be possible to get a first
strike to get a response to strike off
if the soviets attacked and so they
delegated authority to individual
commanders to do a discretionary launch
and daniel's talked about this in his
book and i i you know it's just one of
those issues where maybe it's just too
complex for
people to talk about in mainstream media
or maybe people dismiss daniel ellsberg
as a you know a nutty kook but he's not
you know this is a highly intelligent
man who to this day
is as worried about the security of the
nuclear weapons repositories in the
united states and the soviet union and
china russia britain france india
pakistan
israel he's as worried about all of
these nuclear weapons now as he was back
then if not more
and we should we all should be
and and hypothetically what if
what if
the phenomenon that we're now seeing in
our skies is trying to send us a message
when it goes on the radar as these
anomalies craft and it almost starts a
nuclear war does that not
contradict the hypothesis that they're
here to save us should they not know
about that
well the war didn't happen did it
maybe they were sending a message i mean
we don't know i've got no idea
i mean um
there's an amazing i've i've got the
documents in my files somewhere but um i
didn't put it in the book and maybe i
should have done but
there's an amazing bit of work that's
been done by a researcher in los angeles
called brad sparks about
objects that
have actually crossed
they've flown directly towards
presidential uh
residences or camp david or washington
dc
and there's been clear responses it's
almost like whatever it's doing it's
it's saying
um
hey you guys you know for all of your
weapons deterrent systems we can go and
do whatever we want wherever we want
and
maybe the point of manifesting this
capacity to
the most powerful country on the planet
is
to remind them that they're still just
human
uh and that mistakes can still be made
and to
make them think twice about the
[Music]
the control and oversight procedures
that they have on the deployment of some
of the more sensitive weaponry
uh i mean one of the things i didn't
realize until i spoke to bob salas i
always assumed that somebody like bob
salas the guy who was in the icbm
minuteman silo in the 1960s
i assumed that
he
could only launch his weapons once a
code was put into his system
and then with that authorization he and
his colleague could turn the key and it
would actually work
what he explained to me was that at that
period in the 1960s
yes they required an authorization
before they were allowed to turn their
key but they could still turn their key
which which to me seems insane
that you could have two guys in a silo
in the middle of the midwest in the usa
who
if they decided to go crazy for a moment
could just simultaneously turn their
keys and cause the nuclear war
i mean the control and oversight of
nuclear weapons really is a very serious
concern and
especially now that we've got hydrogen
bombs that the likes of which the world
has never seen used in um
[Music]
in anger and god forbid that we ever did
i mean there's a great um
i was playing with this with one of my
daughters the other night this is what
we do at home
there's a great website you can go to
where you can actually measure the
impact of certain shapes of
thermonuclear bombs on different cities
and so
the other night we were dropping bombs
on canberra and sydney and just seeing
what would happen with the radiation
over where we live
and so we decided we'd be a lot better
off if a nuclear bomb was dropped on
sydney because all the radioactive waste
would go north from where we are but if
canberra gets a bomb dropped on it which
it probably will we're completely
screwed and i i'm being flippant here
but you know the the incredible thing to
me is that as a society
humanity lives
with the ever-present reality that there
are people sitting in silos right now
with their hands on the key
ready to accept the authorization codes
to launch their nuclear weapons and
when i was with
lou elizondo in wyoming we spent a
couple of days a few days in wyoming
with him and he lives in a beautiful
part of the cowboy country there
and
he lives not too far away from the huge
mountain that featured in close
encounters as a third kind and so i i
said to him look i really apologize for
asking you this but if you've got two
hours where we can take you to
that mountain and get some pictures of
you with that iconic mountain behind you
and he very kindly agreed
and as we were driving the few hours
along the highway there and back
he started pointing out to me
tracks
leading off the road
and he said what do you think they are
and i said i don't know and all i could
see was just an aerial and a what looked
like a
a gas canister or something and i said i
don't know fuel fuel bowsers or
something
and he went the icbm launched silos
and as we were driving through wyoming
my whole understanding of this beautiful
landscape changed
and i was just thinking of that scene
from terminator where new york just
explodes you know all the bombs start
going off
because we're in this beautiful
absolutely stunning cowboy country
there's mountains with snow and
you know there's literally guys with
leather chaps walking through bars you
know it's just the most gorgeous part of
the world
and then the reality that i couldn't
help but notice as we were driving along
every few miles there would be another
one of these little tracks and they're
all built the same way because the same
contractor builds them the same way
and it's just amazing to me that in this
day and age
there would have been dozens of these
tracks leading up to what
you know there's two men sitting inside
a room
ready to turn the key on the president's
orders
and just trying to think of what that
landscape would look like with icbms
coming out of the silos all over that
landscape
it's so incongruous it's such an
incredible thing i think people don't
like thinking about it but
the reality is that friends of mine that
know these things that work in
national security they say we're closer
to nuclear war now than ever before
and the international environment now is
so unstable there are so many risks that
there might be an inadvertent nuclear
attack of some kind
and we need we need to
try and avert that
and maybe just maybe there is some
intelligence that's trying to let us
know about that
have you heard of the proposition that
the aliens are concerned with us
starting a war rather than stopping a
war
that they feed off of suffering
oh god now you're getting really
depressing please give me hope i like to
uh
i like to think of benevolence
intelligence i like to think that
something that's vastly technologically
superior to us and probably more
intelligent than us has developed a
moral values system that understands the
importance of utilitarian ideas and
moral decency and ethical values
tom delong freaked me out i spent a lot
of time listening to tom de long's
interviews where he was talking about
what he'd been told
by the general and other people inside
intelligence services before he went
public with ttsa in 2016-2017
and
you know i actually think it's
really interesting because he talked
about warring gods and
jealous gods and i thought it was crazy
and then
the dnc leaked happened
and it turned out that he really was
talking i mean it's beyond doubt people
don't realize this and again it's just
an amazing oversight by mainstream media
that they haven't picked up on this
the leaked wikileaks emails leaked by
the russian gru believe it or not who
hacked the democratic national committee
who tried to gain intelligence that
might help trump win against hillary
clinton
the dnc emails show irrefutably that tom
delong was telling the truth
when he said that he was in
communication with generals general neil
mccaslin general michael carey
robert weiss of skunk works lockheed
martin
john podesta
and other senior officers in space
command the central intelligence agency
and different sections of the us
military were giving this punk rock
rockstar briefings talking to him about
what they knew
what i find fascinating is
journalists look for evidence you look
for corroborative evidence and so i'd
listen to tom and i like everybody else
i've giggled and i thought this guy's
completely bananas you know there's one
particular coast coast interview where i
just thought he'd gone nuts
and then i remember feeling very humbled
and quite ashamed of myself when i
realized oh my god and i'm going through
the dnc emails and going
hell's bells if he was telling the truth
about this
could it be he was telling the truth
about the general when the general said
it was the cold war and we found a life
form
could it be possibly true that the
general did say that to him
and if he didn't why would tom lie about
that
you know
why hasn't hillary clinton been asked
questions about this why was she clearly
clearly there were plans underway and
this is evidenced by these emails
there were plans underway by
john podesta in conjunction with certain
generals in the u.s military former and
serving
to do something about a disclosure
that's revealed in these emails they
were talking about telling the american
public something shortly after hillary
clinton became president
there was going to be some kind of
disclosure in 2017.
i i just find it mind-blowing that that
you can have corroboration of the fact
that these meetings were taking place
with de long with very senior officials
he was telling the truth about that
and yet people haven't exercised the
curiosity to go well
if that was true
was tom telling the truth about warring
gods and evil aliens and
you know is that true could it be true
i think we should be asking these
questions
because something was going on and we
still don't know what it was and i just
find it mind-blowing that the new york
times the washington post
cbs abc nbc haven't gone
mrs clinton
nor stop it mrs clinton mrs clinton what
was going on what was going on why was
john podesta meeting generals why were
there talks of disclosure why are these
questions not being asked
is it just me that thinks this have i
gone crazy
what was it that tom delonge said that
freaked you out
he oh there's so many interviews you can
i mean i don't want to sound like i'm
overly promoting my book but you know
i've detailed them in my book
uh he talked about warring gods
and and i guess if you're talking about
future humans that are so
technologically advanced maybe they are
gods
but
um basically there's a
uh a conflict going on
uh
and that there were evils evil aliens
that were indeed you know there were
abductions and there were
humans being killed and you know it's
quite shocking stuff
and look i wouldn't believe any of it
for a moment
or give it any kind of
airing
until i see hard evidence but the fact
that
tom was saying that contemporaneously
with all of these interviews that he was
doing he was also meeting with generals
who were telling him these things
you know he actually describes in one of
his books
how he actually
sat down he got on a private plane was
told to go to a particular airport in
the midwest somewhere
and then he met
a very senior general in a back cafe
in a diner somewhere in the middle of
nowhere
and the general basically agreed to meet
him and give him a briefing
and he really did say you know it was
the cold war we we lived in constant
fear for our lives we thought the world
was going to you know explode
and then we found a life form
and
and then what after that
oh look i i i read the book you know
seriously i don't want to i don't want
for people who would like to buy it
so basically the um
you know tom's made a whole series of
quite elaborate claims about what he was
told incredible detail of
warring alien groups who are trying to
control the human race and
he actually said that when people came
to understand what was really going on
they would actually think that the
reasons for the secrecy were actually
quite laudable
and that the public would actually be
grateful for what's being done on their
behalf and who knows they may very well
be
but um
[Music]
to this day what is it now it's um
six years since one of tom's last
interviews where he was talking about
this stuff
uh you know he obviously set up ttsa i
think in the expectation that hillary
clinton was going to be the president
and she was going to be a disclosure
president
and no matter what hillary clinton or
bill have said publicly it's quite
obvious that there were negotiations
going on behind the scenes because the
emails with john podesta show very very
clearly
there's a key one where neil mccaslin
who
i mean he's two-star general who was
the guy who ran
the
what we know as the foreign technology
division at wright-patterson air force
base
i mean if there is somewhere in america
where
non-human technology is being stored
hypothetically that's where that's where
it's gone
and and he was purportedly
briefing
dulong
and this is shown in these wikileaks
emails
and they are leaked emails that were
never intended to be public that were
clearly regarded by the dnc as being
highly secure
and guess who leaked them the russians
the russians hacked into the dnc
leak leaking them thinking that the
exchanges might assist donald trump in
his re-election ask yourself why this
why that would have been the case
but um whatever you think of trump or
whatever you think of clinton the
reality is these conversations were
taking place
and i think that's important and it's a
piece of history that nobody has asked
questions about i've
asked frankly i've asked colleagues of
mine in
major national newspapers and tv
networks in the states why they haven't
looked at this and all of them have been
unaware of it
all of them have been unaware of the
significance of these momentous emails
where
you know it's only when you actually
look at what tom delong was saying that
he'd been briefed into the existence of
an alien spacecraft retrieval program by
members of the u.s government that there
was a back engineering program going on
underway but also at the same time there
was a war going on between competing
civilizations that were competing for
control of the human race i mean
mind-boggling stuff
uh
basically it was also talking about how
ancient there'd been previous
civilizations on this planet before
humanity arrived
and they've been wiped out in cataclysms
and
you know a lot of the evidence of
old civilizations if you actually
analyzed them properly were not
derived from current human civilization
i mean
mind-boggling stuff and all credit to
tom frankly i am a sincere apology for
my appalling american imitation of his
american accent and my audible version
of my book but uh
you know he's been proved right he's
been proved right he really was having
these meetings and when
when he appeared on uh
rojas coast coast and
different um
uh different uh
uh
podcasts he was um
laughed at you know people derided him
they says our tom neuron's gone crazy
but all credit to him
it will appear
that from the corroboration that exists
in the wikileaks emails on at least some
points we can confirm he was absolutely
telling the truth
so what else was he telling the truth
about
what else was he being told by the us
military and more importantly
was that the truth or was it
disinformation
i mean were they using tom to get a
story out there that they knew people
would pick up on because he was a
popular figure
that's always a possibility as well you
always have to be mindful for the
possibility of disinformation